you can see I got over there on the
left-hand side my normal force just like
there was before all of my things that
are same then I started to do the
lateral force ok now I'm glad two people
draw an extra things on the diagram
because you want to get the angles right
you get the angles wrong and you'll get
your sine and cosine mixed up and then
it's impossible to get right after that
so invest the time and make this a good
diagram ha hold on a second all this is
is the axis right this is just the axis
so if I have a value here and then I go
and if I working and then this turns out
to be a negative number that just means
oh that's down the hill right but if
it's positive that's the way it's going
ok so I've got this set up so that I
know what direction positive is while I
might get a negative right and that's
fine that just means I'm pointing this
way instead of that way ok so I'm
defining this to be positive because I
think that makes sense you know numbers
go bigger that way so I'm going to be
drawing sine theta cos theta etc and I'm
going to go and clutch my numbers and
find out the sign of El right I'll find
out in a minute now this guy here
represents the bottom of my embankment
right so I've got feet of air which
means in this diagram where's theta it's
just corresponding angles right cool
super easy ok yeah so there we go so so
therefore the horizontal part of my
friction force my lateral force is going
to be it's going to be caught on it's
gonna be the adjacent side here so
that's all cause they are right and then
your vertical component over here is
going to be all sign things very good ok
fantastic now I've Stewart gravity over
there I'm now going to ball everything
together so vertically it's stationary
right because I don't want it to be
moving so friction force is going to
this lateral force is going to be what
ensures I don't move back and forth ok
so have a look at all of my up down
forces right
these two are bottom I left which way
are they facing positive they're both
going up okay so i'm going to write and
cause the plus L sine theta right both
facing up and then this guy is negative
yes ok so I'm going to hello doesn't
like me talking about these forces okay
I'm gonna write that now I'm going to do
one more thing which will be a little
bit like why does he do that okay and it
will be revealed i wonder when you work
out why i do this this line here i'm
going to multiply through by sine theta
okay that's going to give me this i'm
gonna multiply everything through my
sign Athena like so okay i'm going to
call this guy equation I've already got
creative one somewhere we call this
equation 3 okay I had one into when I
was resolving these guys okay right so
it's what i get from the vertical
component horizontally I've got my
uniform circular motion so have a look
at your horizontal forces you have this
guy facing toward the center this guy
facing away so this is positive this is
negative agree yeah we can I'm gonna
write them well okay so i have defined
i've defined our two positive so i can't
swap me way honest i make a big hoo-ha
about it I don't see any reason to swap
it stay with me right this is positive
so I've got L cos theta this is negative
that guy over there yep and in total all
of those are created uniform circular
motion which is minus MB squared on our
is that ok now maybe like too many
negatives right this is why sometimes
'text-icle face it the other way so i'm
going to multiply everything through by
negative 1 like so and then I'm going to
do one more thing i'm going to multiply
everything by cos theta now again you
don't know what I know which tells me
why I should do this but maybe it's
starting to emerge
this is equation for what do I try to
find it yet trying to find out oops
thank you cuz there thank you good fun
so if I want L then I'm going to have to
get all of this other end stuff out of
the way right and these are the only two
simultaneous equations I've got to do it
right can you see how what I'm doing
here basically is I'm solving
simultaneous equations and what
techniques do we have for solving
simultaneous equations substitution and
elimination and which one we're doing
here elimination because look I've made
these guys the same so they're gonna
cancel if i subtract so i'm going to do
in the table of equation 3 take away
question four okay can you see it so
these inside theater clustered is
cancelled I'm going to get left with
this that's going to be a double
negative well look that's super
convenient right and then on the right
hand side I have all this stuff mg
sine-theta take away MVC like so yeah
you're with me so now here sine squared
plus cos squared that's really nice on
the right I'm just going to take out a
factor of M so I've got these guys here
okay
right now we're pretty much there you
see this right this this is just
substitution now this is just
substitution because mass is to find G
will go with 9.8 theta is defined
velocity is you're going to have to
convert one hundred eighty kilometers
per hour into m/s and we know the radio
sets a thousand and we already know feel
ok now I'm going to save you a bit of
calculator work for for part 1 i'm just
going to give you the number and i'm
gonna ask you to help me ok for part 1
and 180 km/h actually it's already mad
at me 3000 sorry I'm actually just gonna
go straight to the actual labor force ok
what I've calculated is this once you go
ahead and your calculator does all of
all the all the grunt work this is the
number that I've gotten a thousand a
thousand okay so this is the number i
get now interpret from me what this
means tell me what this means am I going
too fast or too slow for this curve too
fast right so therefore my car once they
go away and skid out ok so my wheels are
like not pull it together so they apply
friction force down the hill right
toward the center you see it okay so
this is 1753 Newton's down ago ok damn
it oh let me just quickly finish you can
see you can see the reason why this
number goes negative is look you can be
where is V in the equation B is being
subtracted right does that make sense so
a larger V means this gets more and more
and more negative are you with me so
that's why this is me when you did part
2 this is the number i get when you
substitute in thank you so interpret for
me what does this mean what is yeah the
car's gone too slow what does what is
gravity doing to the car
pulling down the hill and tires like go
up the hill they push the car and that's
why it'll stay vertically stationary
does that make sense so I say therefore
630 Newton's not down the hill what's
not okay